[Music]
the large bathers by Paul Cezanne is a
painting that dawns on you at first you
see the whole a group of women bathing
by a river a subject that's anything but
original the canvas is composed in a
balanced geometry of triangles one for
the group on the left one for those on
the right and one comprising them all
bounded by the leaning trees but after a
minute you start to notice things like
the figures behind the river or the
swimmer in the water or almost
disturbingly that none of the bathers
have any definable faces or that their
bodies seem to fold into one another as
if they'd been painted over but not
completely the more you stare at it the
more the canvas seems a chaos of
elements deliriously rendered with a
spontaneity that feels almost negligent
of course we know that saison labored on
this painting for seven years all the
way up to his death spontaneity is
certainly part of the message but the
painter was intensely purposeful in what
he wanted to say and how he wanted to
convey it from our perspective across
the gulf of cubism and all imaginable
forms of abstraction it's heart first
says Anne's distortions of color and
form to shock us yet that's exactly what
they did in 1906 and the paintings first
exhibition it's not wrong to say that
says an initiated what became the 20th
century's endless experimentation as
Picasso himself said says an is the
father of us all in this way he can sort
of be seen as the bridge between what
came before and all that was to come the
large bathers reaches in the past
recalling similar scenes of nudes or
bathers like those by Titian or Nicolas
Poussin or Thomas Eakins among others
certain of the figures evoke postures
from older works the woman on the Left
striding upwards with the tree for
example bears a resemblance to an 18th
century sculpture of the goddess Diana
or take the woman on the right here
who's raised knee and shoulders remember
the classical venus de milo by
Alexandros of antioch and perhaps it
should be noted that none of
14 women we see here were drawn from
real models Susanne took his examples
from other works and picture books
adding to that disquieting sense of
remove that these figures have from any
identifiable personalities that removed
that alienation is echoed everywhere in
the painting of the 14 women six are
simply turned away from the viewer a few
are even in the process of dissolving or
emerging from the foliage all around
them most unsettling of all the figures
are popped with areas of white which on
closer examination proves not to be any
paint at all but the bare canvas itself
interrupting the scene as if some force
from a world beyond what is seasoned
trying to do here what are these
disturbances amount to what are the
effects of his short flat brushstrokes
of distilling everything into its
geometrical basis or freezing in paint
that which doesn't appear to be a scene
at all but something on the verge of
becoming a scene or else of dissolving
out of one says an is emerging out of
Impressionism a movement that was
obsessed with how colors and light
really appeared to the eye how did the
atmosphere the rain or the sunset affect
the visual impression of the observer
the Impressionists explored this by
going out into nature and painting
rapidly applying just what they saw to
the canvas in front of them say zan took
the palette of the Impressionists
retaining the brilliant often surprising
colors used to evoke nature's effect on
us but he took color a step further and
applied it to express form as well ever
since the Renaissance depth was rendered
via perspective Cezanne seems to realize
that Renaissance perspective is only a
kind of code by which we understand the
third dimension in a canvas seeing
itself the perception as distinct from
the understanding may not work on those
principles it may be far more on
than that this is why he didn't shy away
from distortion of objects of using
colors to bring elements in the
background forward or melt things in the
foreground into the architecture of
colors that hold them there there's a
difference between the way we know what
we see and how we actually see it our
minds are so incredibly good at taking
the anarchic varieties of sensible
experience and within milliseconds
composing them into intelligible holes
it happened so fast that we can't even
access that actual moment of perception
and for the most part we should be happy
about that because raw experience like a
kind of trauma is just too much for us
to a stand-in the large bathers Cezanne
uses his various techniques to visit
that moment of perception confronted
with it aesthetically all that's
unsettling about experience is frozen
for our contemplation in life it's a
bridge we just can't cross and take a
look at that man on the other side of
the river many think that this figure is
say zan himself situated between the
classical constructed diorama of bathers
and the pastoral impressionistic church
seen in the distance now I bet if we
could turn the painting around and see
it from that perspective it would look
just as sensual erotic and beautiful as
something by Titian or any other painter
who depicted a similar scene in the past
but from our vantage the one say zan
gave to us were allowed a fugitive
access to something far more disturbing
the real
hey everybody if you want to help me
keep making these videos I'm doing a big
push for patreon pledges everything
helps as little as one dollar per video
it really is the pledges that allow me
to continue making this channel and the
more I get the the more time and effort
I can spend on making really cool stuff
and I have a lot of stuff in the works
right now which is gonna be really great
yeah if you think the nerd writer is
something that you're not seeing
anywhere else and you want to see more
of it
pledging is really the way to help me so
thank you so much and here are some more
videos
[Music]